[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we have with us toyota bay
fish sauce
i had a question i was wondering and uh
i i wonder if you guys ever had
experience like this but ask her first
because she's weird like that have you
cause she's weird like that yeah have
you ever
either been dating somebody or you liked
somebody
and then a person came forward with some
bit of information that ruined it for
you
where they either told you something
they did or said
any type of influence that made you go
ah damn uh no no
that's never happened to you not even
like his penis
i have a weird one certain situations
like that i would just want to find out
myself okay because it's like i don't
know how reliable
the source is
so
unless it's like oh he like killed
somebody
or like well that's a criminal record
right right so i'm just like
i guess that still counts yeah but if
it's like just little [ __ ]
like to their character or like just
even how they are in bed [ __ ] like that
i'll be like um i'll try to find out
that's really nice yeah i have a weird
one so i uh in community college
i met this chick at a party um she was
cool super attracted to her and she was
super fun and fun funny story we've
actually been on a date a double date
with me and her and then gio and her
boyfriend at the time [ __ ]
and she was like she was like one of
those super down people that is just
down for like
anything so like you guys go to the
beach want to [ __ ] in the water let's do
it like anything is cool you know and so
she was super fun and then i thought oh
this is a dream relationship like she
was she was uh attractive and she was
fun and she was super nice and then one
day we were just chilling i think we got
like mcdonald's or some [ __ ] sitting in
the car
and uh she was like
i was like oh how's that like e-contest
or whatever and then she was like i did
pretty good i'm not for reals i was like
what how'd you do and she was like oh i
got a c
and then for some reason i think i would
the mode that i was in at that time is i
[ __ ] up so much in high school in
college i was trying to like crush it
you know so for me to go
wait you think c is good
you just like
i just couldn't unsee the dumbass
anymore and i was like
i need to get out of here
i couldn't unsee the dumbass no matter
how fun
the other dates were or anything that we
did is i was just like [ __ ] this isn't
good this isn't going to work
i get that i don't see the c
oh yeah i was just like so her teacher
broke the deal for you her teacher
basically because he gave her c
her attitude towards the scene
i did pretty good
yeah but she did say pretty good
it wasn't a solid oh yeah i crushed it
so if she had said pretty good if she
instead said really bad i got a c it
would have you would have been fine it
would have been cool yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah cause it's more like her
expectations
yeah
you just saw her standards yeah and her
standards were like [ __ ] yeah yeah but
bart's standard had just changed like
the season before i know
he just can't he doesn't alive so
judgmental see i was on the verge of
drowning i'm like
there's not enough beef not enough space
on this [ __ ] floatation yeah don't
bring me anybody
no water
you said you had something you said no
this reminds me of the [ __ ] we did
yesterday where the where the lady got
married to that guy she was cleaning the
house when he was gone and she found a
[ __ ] box of child porn
remember that [ __ ] we did that yesterday
i think that's very i think that's very
different we did we didn't did a jk news
about that [ __ ] we did i don't think so
we didn't do that yesterday
all right
he has a double life he has another news
channel
[Music]
[ __ ]
damn
[Music]
i thought we did a jk news about a lady
all of a sudden i know all of us were
like i don't think so
who was like
who was like i don't know man this is
some [ __ ] shady [ __ ] she was madly in
love all this [ __ ] and then one day when
her husband was out she was cleaning out
the house there was a box she opened up
that box and and and she was horrified
she was heartbroken
and then she she [ __ ] ratted his
house out she had about all this [ __ ]
yeah was it his child porn he was
holding it for a friend like his
collection oh like personally
no no no it was just she found that [ __ ]
no we didn't we didn't do that yesterday
because we i look at the article
did he film that
or was someone else film that was his
collection i'm talking about like if you
i i don't know maybe this happened to me
more than other people but like because
like you know when you date somebody
that's part of sort of a similar social
circle that you're kind of
acquainted with someone from that side
could go you sure you want to date her i
don't know man she blah blah blah blah
like they'll just throw it there oh
because they know about their reputation
yeah like something like that that only
happened like afterwards i remember
it was after i stopped talking with one
girl and i found out that like she was
like dude she had sex with that guy and
i was like oh yeah yeah that [ __ ]
dude i was like i was like no thank you
i'm out
i did actually now i remember i was
dating someone and a mutual friend that
knew her before me
hit me up and says you know she's a
whole right and i'm like duh
yeah
he tried to
and then this is what i found out later
double down i love it because i like her
i love that i like her i don't give a
[ __ ] she's sucking my dick not his right
so then like
it just sounded so weird i'm like why
are you trying so [ __ ] hard to shame
this person yeah what i found out is one
of his closest friends was bitter
because he wanted her so he was trying
to [ __ ] us up yeah see but it was true i
guess she she was going to parties and
having fun but she was single so there's
nothing wrong with that
and then his friend his friend wanted to
i guess [ __ ] and then he was feeling
weird because he couldn't get any but
she was [ __ ] other guys so he felt
like a little [ __ ]
and then so he was being a good friend
to his friend trying to break us up ah
that's when i was like [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
and then you know but i'm like it's i i
i think like to me you have to be a weak
person to be like oh really uh the
ground dating is actually a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god my reputation is ruined like
[ __ ] you dude shut the [ __ ] up like like
you don't know if behind the scenes
they're trying to do something like that
that's why i'm like usually what it is
yeah yeah
and that's the only thing that's ever
probably come up for me too i don't
think it was any like a character flaw
personality trait it would only just be
like hey you know this person has sex
with this person yeah it's like okay
that was it and i was like so so she has
practice yeah now she can [ __ ] me better
like what i don't care i was dating
somebody and then i did get a couple
warnings uh about it oh this person has
sex with this person i was like okay
well
in college that happens and then it'd be
like but they also had sex with this
person that but okay and but they also
had sex with this person now i'm like oh
[ __ ] damn
i remember confronting her because you
know similar circle type stuff i
remember like asking
and then um
at the time she was just like i can't
believe people are like talking about me
like that she got really emotional and i
was like man i feel really really bad
but then i also realized like later on i
was like wait but she didn't say she
didn't
yeah and it was true she didn't
she did have sex with all those people
so yeah but like what's the fault of
having sex with a lot of people nothing
at all i think it was just a matter of
like
why are so many people willing to have
conversations about it outside as well
but i think it might be slightly a
two-way street with it um it's like i
don't it's not to say that everybody's
just trying to be like okay i think this
person must put out the data out there
so that everybody knows i think it's
also maybe like um
it's it's in some way two-way street
where like maybe that person is either
like moving through the community as
well you know what i'm saying and like
it's maybe they're breaking hearts along
the way you know what i'm saying so
they're looking out for you like she's
like yeah yeah this is this is her type
yeah or something yeah so i i think i
was getting more of that those vibes
she's like
am i next is she just using me and
breaking my heart yeah yeah all right i
mean the same goes for guys that are
doing that right like your girlfriends
are gonna tell the girl like hey watch
out for that dude he'd be banging
everybody well this is a thing though
right like um they say that women are
less desirable if they had a lot of
partners there's there are people that
believe that sure and i think um
i would have agreed if i was 18 years
old
right or like i would have agreed when i
was going to church yeah yeah
but there there comes a time when you're
like i lost [ __ ] count so it's like
do you still want a [ __ ] virgin
the hell is wrong with you you're such a
sex haver dude
[Music]
you are a sex advertiser and overall is
my guy once upon a time i lost count in
some religions that is the goal just to
end up with virgins isn't it but why
would you want a virgin that's the thing
is like
it's it's i think it's a weird fetish
right that that they want in the
beginning but then afterwards it's like
why does that matter so much especially
if you're a full-grown adult and then
the older you become you're like
you act you want someone with experience
with life experience you want someone
who's been in a relationship you want
someone who's experienced all of this
[ __ ] and worked out all of that before
they came and met well to be fair
there's people out there that definitely
do want that i think that we're all just
friends because we know that you don't
need that type stuff you know what i
mean
like if there's just people that have
different preferences and whatnot it's
just a matter of like we probably just
don't roll with those people they're
like yo i need virgins only yeah yeah
yeah
it's all down here that sounds like a
creep yeah for sure but you did it very
naturally good for you yeah there's
definitely something weird about a
person who's not a virgin that's like
really gatekeeping and being like i only
[ __ ] virgins that shit's weird that's
weird
that's not like a weird fetish
yeah i knew guys like that too and i was
like what the yeah what's wrong with you
and then and it's funny because i know
guys like that well they were like doing
this in high school and stuff
but then you know obviously things can
change but you always think like because
he this person that i'm thinking of kind
of lives his way on social media like a
very particular like holier than that
type of thing yeah so he's upkeeping
yeah but then in my head i'm like dude i
should know like how like what a little
weirdo you're a sleazeball yeah like
like and i don't hopefully you change i
don't know you know but in my head i
can't help but to feel like uh to be
like that kind of like ignorant though
like when you're in high school like
straight up most of the chicks are
virgins you know what i'm saying like
most people are still are virgins by
that i don't know no versions in high
school yeah
you're such a sex hacker
[Music]
okay let's go around all right let's go
around i was a late bloomer too i think
uh 19.
i forgot i think 16 17.
i was like i was 16. most of my friends
lost their like 14 15 and then if they
were girls they lost it like [ __ ] 13.
i was like 20. i was like 20.
i was late
but he's only been with one girl so
that's the difference
high school sweetheart
it's like a movie yeah oh my god isn't
that the sweetest [ __ ] so disgusting gay
dude isn't that gay
it exists and then yours is crazy huh so
15 20 all right what was your sweat okay
so technically it was eighth grade
12. there's a technicality behind that
okay because
on average thirteen yeah a lot of my
homies lost them when they're like
twelve or thirteen though girls a lot of
them twelve thirteen it might like
people i knew
guys were like fifteen ish yeah okay
yeah cause like i said technically
because we didn't really do anything it
was more so like it was in there and
then we got scared oh okay
oh we going technically all right 17.
technically
eighth grade but like
i didn't start like doing it until like
a freshman so like a year okay yeah yeah
yeah but you saw the trailer to the
movie yeah but that that age though i
remember like because it was so
my school system was
elementary up to sixth grade and then
junior high was seventh and eighth grade
and then high school right and then uh i
remember like in sixth grade
we're playing power rangers on the
[ __ ] playground and then i remember
going to junior high and all of a sudden
everyone's a professional cigarette yeah
and i was like
it was like crash course to adulthood
people make it out and all that [ __ ]
it went from holding hands professional
cigarette smoker yeah to getting [ __ ]
hand jobs yeah to everyone everyone all
of a sudden knowing how to [ __ ] smoke
like all cool and [ __ ] and i'm like wait
no one wants to battle me to be the red
ranger
i guess i'll be the red ranger again
damn
that one year was like boom from fifth
to six is like a crash course dude it is
so what happened in that first time that
you got you said you guys both got
scared both of you guys and you checked
it out
and then i thought i was pregnant off of
that yeah just one wow
just one pump yeah that's a true at that
age i was so that's true i'm scared i
was like damn i think i'm pregnant
you bought a crib and [ __ ] and you're
just like i guess it's time team mother
life
you're in the toy isle of target you're
just looking at baby dolls and you're
like oh my god my life is different
i brought a test and everything and then
i took it and i was like oof
i guess i'm not pregnant
it's true did you start like looking at
the baby food aisle at the grocery store
i was just like really scared
you know i did i went to vegas and at
that time i was like just super scared
and like in my head i you know those
like fortune teller um uh like in yeah
that's hot i already love where this is
going oh the one you pay 50 cents yeah
you mean the robot the fortune teller
robot the turbine in the glass
magic eight ball
in the corner next to the lava lamp i
remember this because like i literally
was like am i pregnant i literally asked
when you're 13. yes
imagine if it responds all loud no you
are not pregnant
shut up shut up it gave me like vague
answers
ask again whether or not you are
pregnant
a vegan answer
that's hilarious i forgot but it it
didn't give me a definite yes or no so i
was like
am i pregnant
maybe
you're only as pregnant as you
feel well i feel really pregnant
your parents are like honey you're not
eating your circus circus buffet what's
wrong
oh nothing
is the beef not beef this time
yeah that's why that happened that
happened my first girlfriend before i
lost my virginity well we lost it to
each other but before we actually had
sex we used to grind a lot and like dry
hump yeah dude that was my favorite and
then she was late like one day in her
period and she called me like in a
frantic like crying was just like do you
think maybe like i don't know maybe
something seeped out between our clothes
and i'm like that's i never learned that
that could happen yeah yeah not through
these anchor blues
i had to be on baggies baby
on
yeah but that's true back then like one
little change in your like what you're
used to you're just like
someone in here is pregnant yeah yeah
because you didn't know yeah
you had no life experience at that point
yeah and then you have the opposite
problem when you're like ain't no way
you're pregnant baby not with me yeah
and it's like oops yeah oops you just
get too confident [ __ ] right you're wild
there's a couple of chicks in my junior
high so like 12 13 and they would come
to school
with their kid and then like one of them
was already pregnant
and just me like in that juxtaposition
from elementary to junior high like
seeing a chick that was pregnant when
she was 12 or 13
i was just like
i don't think i could do that to them i
don't think i got enough like sperm or
just or manhood or whatever
that's not what the red ranger does
[Laughter]
the red ranger would never
because that's also when like puberty
hits people different right and you got
dudes out and you're like hey we're like
best pals right and the next year
they're like it was so important what
the dude i look like i was 12 until i
was 28 years old bro when where did you
go through puberty
like last week you know what's funny i
joke with my wife all the time i'm like
i feel like i'm going through puberty
right now oh
why you saying
i tell my wife all the time i feel like
i'm like bro i'm barely growing hair on
my kneecap wait was adorable bro as of
this year i didn't have hair on my
kneecaps now i got tons of hair on my
kneecaps dude i had my girls girls from
seventh to eighth grade and then like i
was taller than like like all of my like
black friends and stuff and i'm like
yeah man i'm going to get really tall
junior and then in high school uh uh
ninth grade
the tides turned and i'm just like [ __ ]
dude why am i not still growing and
you're all shrinking and stuff yeah it
just went like this and i just shrank
while they went up like a monster in
seventh or eighth grade then huh i was
one of the taller kids did my i went
through puberty in 10th grade and how
tall were you before that so i was 5'2
and 145 pounds yeah at the start of 10th
grade and then at the end of 10th chubby
boy i was 5 10
and 145 pounds
in one year one year holy [ __ ]
i guess sorry
145 i was chubby i was very chubby and
then i went to 5 10 and i was 145 same
thing damn you stretched out
just so you like evened out good for you
man not even like i like got stretched i
was like scrawny lanky
[Music]
in junior high i was like five five and
in high school i was five-six
[Laughter]
i was a big i was a little chubby boy
you were in 10th grade yeah when i went
through puberty i remember being in
[ __ ] science class like uh physical
sciences and we're going for a
presentation when my voice was all
cracking and [ __ ] like that and i
remember people sneaking in the like uh
in the [ __ ] snickering in the [ __ ]
class you'd be like he's going through
puberty the time was rough dude because
you couldn't hide it and i'd be like no
i just lost my voice
laryngitis
i feel like my voice just started
cracking
uh just look at me stop saying dude
my ego my pride it's cute
we're happy for you i'm trying to be you
i'm trying to be i hope you never know
what the puberty dude dude i'm going
through puberty right now hold off as
long as you can hey look at this arm
hair this is a new record you know what
i mean
i have this
nick got no hair i got no i'm like a
dolphin my g like i got no hair on me
get out of here i swear to god
hydrodynamic naked bro come on
[Music]
[Music]
foreign